en el último vídeo introduje la forma
vectorial de la regla de la cadena y
digamos solo para recordar de qué trata
todo esto pues pensemos en esta función
efe que aquí pusimos 100 variables de
entrada pero en realidad no importaba
realmente el número de variables de
entrada verdad entonces digamos tenemos
este espacio que tiene 100 dimensiones y
por supuesto no puedo yo visualizar si
en dimensiones pero no importa digamos
aquí tenemos este espacio con 100
dimensiones o incluso si quieres digamos
contextualizar lo más pensando pensemos
que tiene dos en realidad esto es
irrelevante verdad y esta función lo que
hace es tomar este espacio de 100
dimensiones y transformarlo en la recta
verdad que es justamente nuestro espacio
de salida verdad y más aún acá arriba
tenemos otro espacio verdad el espacio
de entradas de la variable de verdad
entonces tenemos una función que
estas digamos esta variable t
hilo y más bien transforma esta recta y
la manda a este espacio de 100
dimensiones verdad entonces la forma en
la que pensamos esta composición de
funciones verdad sería algo así como una
función f que en lugar de poner estas
100 variables ponemos nuestra función
vectorial vedete verdad vedete es una
función que a cada t le asigna un punto
en este espacio de 100 dimensiones y
está dado de esta forma verdad allí por
supuesto aquí lo que queremos hacer es
ver cómo sería la derivada de esta
función y en realidad eso está dado por
esta fórmula que ya pudimos escribir
desde el vídeo anterior verdad ahora
bien esta fórmula nos dice que hay que
tomar el gradiente de la función f
evaluarla en nuestra función vedette y
hacer el producto punto con la derivada
de la función vectorial vedete donde por
supuesto la función o más bien la
derivada de esta función vectorial
verdad la deriva
con respecto a ti pues simplemente es
calcular la derivada de cada una de
estas componentes verdad entonces sería
la derivada de la primer componente la
derivada de la segunda y así nos
seguimos hasta llegar a la última verdad
a la última a la derivada de la última
componente muy bien y lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es ver cómo es que
esto se parece un montón a la derivada
direccional muy bien entonces de hecho
te recomiendo que veas el vídeo sobre la
derivada direccional para que puedas
repasar un poco de qué trata y en
esencia la derivada direccional nos
decía lo siguiente tomábamos un punto p
digamos consideremos este vector p que
se encuentra en nuestro espacio de
entrada es verdad y tomemos algún vector
w tomemos un vector wv de este vector w
será la dirección en la que nos vamos a
mover en este espacio de entrada es
verdad y decíamos bueno un pequeño
cambio en esta dirección w cómo es que
va a afectar en el cambio de nuestra
efe verdad esa es la idea que trata de
abordar la derivada direccional verdad
entonces de hecho la respuesta está dada
justamente por la derivada direccional
verdad que escribimos como un gradiente
con un subíndice con el subíndice de w
que es la dirección en la que nos
movemos y vamos a calcular esta derivada
direccional en el punto o el vector que
nos interesa que es p verdad y nosotros
ya vimos que esto se calcula como el
gradiente de nuestra función evaluada en
ese punto y hacemos el producto punto
con el vector wv verdad entonces si
nosotros observamos esta fórmula de la
derivada direccional y observamos la de
la regla de la cadena en digamos
multivariable en realidad podemos ver
que estas dos cosas se parece en verdad
se parecen muchísimo de hecho esta
fórmula que tenemos aquí voy a hacer un
poco de espacio lo podemos justamente
reescribir en términos de la derivada
direccional verdad entonces si nos damos
cuenta de esto lo podríamos ver como
derivada direccional de nuestra función
verdad en este caso será en la dirección
del vector b prima de t verdad será en
la dirección del vector de prima de t y
tendremos que evaluar en el punto v de t
en el punto verde y esta es una forma
muy bonita y digamos compacta en la que
podemos escribir la regla de la cadena
multivariable pero utilizando derivadas
direccionales en entonces si quisiéramos
pensar de qué trata esto digamos déjenme
borrar por ejemplo todo esto que tenemos
aquí vamos a borrar todo esto para que
tengamos espacio para deducir por qué
tiene tanto sentido pensar en derivadas
direccionales muy bien entonces en
esencia lo que está haciendo la función
vedette es que cada uno de estos puntos
te lo asocia con un punto en este
espacio de 100 dimensiones entonces
quizás se ve algo así es una una curva
digamos y si ahora pensamos digamos en
un punto o brt es decir un punto de esta
curva aquí tenemos el punto de dt verdad
pues la forma en la que podemos pensar a
la derivada de esa función en este punto
particular es justamente como
tangente verdad a esta curva y que nos
indica esencialmente la dirección en la
que nos estamos moviendo verdad entonces
porque tiene sentido pensar a la regla
de la cadena digamos en términos de
derivadas direccionales bueno recordemos
que es lo que significa esto estamos
calculando la derivada con respecto a t
de esta función verdad quiere decir que
tomamos un pequeño empujoncito en este
espacio donde vive la variable de verdad
estamos haciendo un pequeño cambio y
esto causa un pequeño cambio también en
la dirección de nuestra curva verdad y
esto causa un pequeño cambio en nuestro
espacio de 100 dimensiones verdad y será
ese cambio en la dirección de la
derivada de la función vectorial b y al
mismo tiempo esta derivada indica cómo
nos estamos moviendo pero luego esto
este pequeño movimiento también cambia
la salida de nuestra función
efe verdad y eso es lo que dicta la
derivada direccional aquí tendríamos
este cambio en f verdad y eso es lo que
dicta la derivada direccional de hecho
por eso la notación que a veces se
utiliza para denotar a la derivada
direccional es justamente como si fuera
una derivada parcial con respecto a la
dirección en la que nos estamos moviendo
verdad esencialmente es hacemos un
pequeño cambio en la dirección del
vector w y vemos cómo cambia la salida
de nuestra función y luego calculamos la
proporción verdad y hacemos entender un
límite a cero
entonces si nos damos cuenta toda esta
esta serie de composiciones y de cambios
es es una forma muy bella de comprender
la regla de la cadena multivariable
verdad pues estamos pensando en esta
curva que está digamos siendo recorrida
en este espacio de 100 dimensiones
verdad está descrita por la función de
dt y la dirección y la rapidez con la
que nos movemos determina el cambio en
la salida verdad así que espero que con
esto tengamos una mejor idea del
qué es la regla de la cadena y la
derivada direccional